I want to get to the docu-series being
Mike Tyson oh man it's like now that I
get reality so don't think of the
reality show okay guys not a reality
show it's a six-part series of being
Mike Tyson hanging around doing
reflective stuff like you had a great we
have a clip here where you surprised
Evander Holyfield he will have quite a
history with well thought the surprise
Amanda but this watch it
okay well this is I think we set this up
Evander is out promoting his hot sauce
yeah I thought he had game come house
when I bitter there because it tastes
like ass you know
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you should be worrying about the
tastiness years where you surprised him
okay let's take a look I love the
surprise I'm gonna be such an
introverted guy you know surprise it was
so awesomely good reaction out of them
[Music]
why
so you surprise them we support each
other you know I know if I come there
that would be moving more support so
anything I could do to help them that's
what I'm gonna do that you're interested
now in your boxing promoter you want to
and I do promote yes I promote my last
fight and it was pretty successful and
and it superseded the reign of the ESPN
believed it would happen and they want
to do it again and I'm really grateful
what kind of fighter are you looking for
what who are you looking what are you
looking for in a fighter when you're
looking for a young you know I want to
look for a guy well similar than me God
is just some he wants to be somebody
that's like maybe the insecure guy maybe
people don't respect his family with
respect right right someone who has that
yeah yeah something to prove no that he
wants to hurt somebody I want somebody
that I'm you know because that's what
war is war is on the destruction of your
enemy or his total surrender under the
other and I want somebody that believes
in that theory of fighting right no
fighting then people can win fights you
know people could win fights and and
have long reins but if they're not
exciting it doesn't mean anything I
could have ran for two years but he was
exciting and making a hundred million
dollars within those two years but God
have a long range he's a champion for
twenty years but people don't care the
family not right and that's really
what's fighting all about about
entertainers about show business you
have to be the most um entertaining
fighter to get the most attention